SKEPTICISM ABOUT THE PARIS
ACCORD AND SAYS TWIT HURL U.S.
BUSINESS.
I'M CAROLINE SHIVELY.
NOW BACK TO "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE."
>> Laura: JUST WHAT IS SPECIAL
COUNSEL BOB MUELLER
INVESTIGATING AND WHY?
OUR NEXT GUEST ARGUES THE MEDIA
JOINING US WITH MORE, ANDY
McCARTHY.
ANDY, I LOVE YOUR COLUMNS,
PERIOD.
>> THANKS, LAURA.
>> Laura: YOU'RE SO GOOD.
I LOVED YOUR MOST RECENT ONE
WHERE YOU RAISE THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER MUELLER HAS EVEN PROVEN
OR EVEN HAS A SENSE, CLEAR
SENSE, THAT RUSSIA HACKED INTO
OUR SYSTEM'S PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION.
EXPLAIN.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
I'M NOT QUESTIONING THE FINDINGS
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
I WOULD STIPULATE THAT RUSSIA
HAD A CYBER ESPIONAGE OPERATION
AGAINST THE 2016 ELECTION.
WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON IS THE
FACT THAT THAT IS AN
INTELLIGENCE JUDGMENT.
IT'S A PROBABILITY.
THEIR REPORT EVEN SAYS THE FACT
THAT WE RENDER A JUDGMENT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN PROVEN
IT AS A MATTER OF FACT.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE WITH
MUELLER'S INVESTIGATION, IT'S A
PROSECUTORIAL EXERCISE.
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE TO PROVE
EVERY ESSENTIAL ELEMENT OF THE
SCHEME, OF THE CRIME, BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT TO THE
SATISFACTION UNANIMOUSLY OF 12
JURORS.
SO EVEN IF IT'S OKAY FOR THE
TO ASSUME THAT RUSSIA HAS THESE
OPERATIONS ABOUT OUR COUNTRY,
DOES NOT RELIEVE MUELLER OF THE
NEED TO PROVE IT BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
I DON'T THINK HE CAN.
THE INTELLIGENCE REPORT SAYS IT
WOULD COMPROMISE METHODS OF
INTELLIGENCE.
WE KNOW THE FBI NEVER TOOK
CUSTODY OF AND DID THEIR OWN
EXAMINATION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
IN YOUR PIECE THAT THEY BASED --
WHEN ROD ROSENSTEIN -- HE
BASICALLY PANICKED AND CALLED
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL WERE
ASKING QUESTIONS.
MUELLER.
MUELLER IS FACING HIS
INVESTIGATION WITH ROSENSTEIN ON
THE CONTACTS WITH RUSSIA, WHICH
DURING A CAMPAIGN, AS YOU POINT
OUT, THAT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
MOST CAMPAIGNS HAVE SOME
IS THE OPERATIVE ONE.
CONTACTS PROBLEMATIC OR
INCRIMINATING IS IF THEY
INDICATED COMPLICITY IN AN
ACTUAL ESPIONAGE SCHEME.
YOU NEVER GET THERE UNTIL YOU
CAN PROVE THE ESPIONAGE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
I DON'T THINK HE CAN.
>> ANDY, LET'S GO TO PETER
STROZK, OTHER PEOPLE IN THE FBI
AND THEIR ABILITY TO BE TRULY
OBJECTIVE AND LOOKING AT THIS
INVESTIGATION.
TO MY EYE, WE HAVE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NOT JUST --
THEY'RE NOT JUST DEMOCRATS, THEY
THEIR TEXTS OR TWEETS OR
COMMENTARY DURING DEBATES AND SO
FORTH.
YOU SORT OF HAVE -- THE JURY IS
OUT FOR YOU ON PETER STROZK.
WHY?
>> AS I UNDERSTAND IT AND AS
COMEY TESTIFIED TO A CLOSED
SESSION, ACCORDING TO THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL," AS THEN FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY TESTIFIED TO A
CLOSED SESSION OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IN MARCH,
THE REASON THEY HADN'T BROUGHT
ANY CASE AGAINST FLYNN AT THAT
POINT IS BECAUSE THE AGENTS THAT
INTERVIEWED HIM BELIEVED HIM AND
THAT WAS STROZK.
SO THE FACT THAT FLYNN PLEADED
GUILTY TO LYING IN THAT
INTERVIEW WAS NOT STROZK'S IDEA.
EVIDENTLY STROZK WAS NOT PUSHING
THAT.
END.
MUELLER'S POOR JUDGMENT
ENLADDERING THIS RIDICULOUSLY
INFLATED 17-LAWYER TEAM WITH
DEMOCRATIC DONORS AND ACTIVISTS
IS NOT ONLY A BIG PROBLEM FOR
THE INVESTIGATION, I THINK WE'RE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO FIND THAT
THE REAL COLLUSION STORY OF THE
2016 ELECTION WAS THE WAY THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION PUT THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
ARMS OF THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THE SERVICE OF THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND A LOT OF THESE
MUELLER LAWYERS COME FROM THE
TOP LEVELS OF THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
REPRESENTING BEN RHODES WHEN HE
WAS TESTIFYING OR BEING
INTERVIEWED BY THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, REPRESENTING THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.